hello went welcome to this video I am
kakarot oh wow I have played two games
against and I don't remember seeing that
name ever okay yeah no idea let's play
the recursion go with them a current
fashion okay the capture yeah we'll
probably just retake check and the check
yeah this line is something that I have
played to myself quite a bit when facing
the Rogo's and yam what is the main
movie as it castles I guess castles
right obvi should be six I wasn't sure
about the move over here that I think
I'm I'm on track and a success is what
they what they play prevent any jumps to
be five and now possibly push it is six
I guess yeah I didn't fare too well with
this in my recent games when I remember
very quick g5s hit me hard what we'll
see
yeah okay to know I don't know how else
to together so what's this out 495 well
this is not turn and not the end of the
world it's something that I can also
just take it's not a not a big deal on
takes d4 is very good and this is not
not a problem here think as the night
comes to his perfect square on d6 not a
problem at all night on d6 is covering
b7 okay so some ideas I can't just go
back to have f5 as an idea f5 therefore
if I go at five now you might have f4
but I have night before in this case so
this does make quite some sense trying
to strike on the King side it's not so
easy for white he's kind of stuck with
this looks here yeah but 95 it's not the
end of the world if I'm getting f4 in
here it looks pretty good I wonder if he
has some kind of peer sacrifice in some
cases oh my yes 20 has to be careful him
that not getting not getting really bad
for wide 94 is coming with the tempo and
so on no looks pretty good for me I
think yeah that makes some sense
okay i just take it yeah this is an
interesting move Nyjah successor is in
the mix but 94 is also quite quite
unpleasant I think I'll just go for 94
96 Queen f6 it's definitely okay for me
not sure if I had something bad about
this is this is not bad at all I have
two hangs and see if I thanks so i will
definitely get the exchange back if i'm
not having anything bad of it okay this
is not bad at all then scrap here just
get the material back or did I have
something better I don't know possible
certainly possible okay groupie aight i
guess getting on the e-file
yeah ruga f8 also was an option
threatening Bishop g4 because f 2 is a
tech yeah okay we gave eight also made
made quite some sense okay what is it
doing here try Jim okay interesting
let's go here prevent any Roxy 2 and so
on and maybe like Bishop before coming I
can it's got rookie three even okay
ok that's a good defense look III was a
good move at least I couldn't I have got
Bishop see to write takes a look that's
the mate that's that's a neat little
shot I hope ok what is the this is the
cleanest one right Queen takes that's
still the made my queen is actually
covered so I can take a three for
example um but what is the what is the
cleanest way to do it you cannot take on
c2 anyway because of the checkmate so I
can just go back yeah that was that's a
clean one
and no it's a bit too late yeah that
line I know I've played that a bit
myself as I mentioned it I could really
handle blacks counter play on the
kingside so well and again here the play
that I got him with the with black um
yeah he did hi morning he didn't find
anything great against it
you're just here
check check check white resigns yeah
well I little I think how to tell how to
tell where white went where'd went
downhill for why'd all this looks kind
of normal but yeah to be honest I'm
really not sure about all this I think
here blacks position is already quite
comfortable the key point is that while
I cannot take this because of tea for
now I'm lot better already so that that
cannot be the solution so rube TX and c6
and the absolute key thing is that black
here will get is night to d6 and this is
the perfect square for the night in this
kind of structure as it is doing many
things simultaneously it looks at two
key squares in the attack and it defends
very nicely the b7 porn so the black
rookie has actually freed on be aided
can go to e8 as it yeah as it often
happens later to support any kinks I
play also the night can jump into c4 in
case of be for the typical minority
attack I think black should be fine
young should be at least equal 92
freeing up the F pawn and we went back
and now have five young I don't know I
think like it's easier to play already
maybe maybe you should consider for just
block everything like this and
back I mean I'm okay yeah no no doubt
but probably it's this kind of echo I
guess now you can go with this before
and somebody have play against your porn
FG 5 it's probably equal but this is
good for black I want to stand in giving
it already gives black some advantage
it's not too not too surprising the
computer wants to go here now that's
actually strong m39 f5 hmm very strong
f3 is not a good move but what is white
smooth then if you cannot go have three
that's stronger than my choice now
because this is I mean it's comfortable
for black but it's not not clearly
better here I think this is all its kind
of equal dash right yeah the engine is
also on equal to five but not anymore
yeah there would be three was a was a
blunder yeah what is that you should
play that the engine gives g3 come back
at Bishop g4 as equal yeah probably
black could try to claim a slight
advantage due to the weakness here but
it's probably not going to Tamela at all
that's going to be equal the auntie em
there's not much to say I'm just up a
ton of material with with various ways
continued for quite a bit chatty but
there is no no hope anymore yeah so this
line continues to get to post my problem
somewhere in my games if I'm on the
white side of problems if I'm like I'm
getting a good position kind of kind of
interesting I don't know probably
yeah maybe white should only go to c5 if
he's got this prepared by before maybe
four chances of an advantage definitely
after after this black is equal pretty
sure about that at least and I've
actually prefer black because it's
easier to play but it shouldn't be
anything serious yeah for black okay
thanks for watching